you're starting centerfielder for the
National League all-stars in tomorrow
night's all-star game in Miami he is
Charlie Blackmon how you doing charlie
Merritt's thanks for having me oh come
on now man I love meeting you in person
and you had get the dinosaur shirt on
and you came in we hung out I always
appreciate that so thanks brother
yeah so what's going through your mind
right now Charlie oh you know I got a
lot going on where I'm off the bus right
now I actually headed over to Marlins
Park okay who's on you just like I seen
all of the National League like I've got
like batting can't sit next to me Silver
Slugger sitting next to me I mean it's
just like if this bus goes down Major
League Baseball will be no more that
that what we got in store okay now
charlie very important here when you go
go back to the hotel is it a same seat
policy you know it's pretty loose
interlac here sure I get it yeah you can
do it ever you want
yeah is Harper driving the bus no no we
got professionals for that kind of thing
I don't yeah where where is Bryce Harper
on that bus right now trying you know
look around I know he must be in the
back with all the cool kids I don't see
him no okay all right we'll see you're
all just now is anybody break out in
song no you know a lot of a lot of small
talk you know like hey I know you from
playing games too but I don't know that
well okay talk about like you know the
weather hmm
really it is so disappointing I got to
be honest with you Charlie a little bit
that yeah I know
so now that's why you got on the phone
with me because we're we're old friends
going back at least two weeks you know
that yeah we'll talk about something
there's weather okay let's do this
tonight what is your approach in hitting
a baseball intending to hit a home run
charlie
I've never done this before I'm not
going to lie you know honestly I'm just
shooting for one like my goal is one
home run okay
and if I hit one I'll just be happy and
you know I'll just have a good time with
the variation who's throwing to you
I've got Darren Holmes our bullpen page
is going to be throwing to me he throws
to beating me every day so I'll feel a
little more comfortable I guess you mean
Darren Holmes the former major league
pitcher Darren oh yeah yeah yeah that's
him
hey are you there Eric I'm going to turn
to my Rich Eisen show researcher right
now Eric Zirin door for el Zorro look up
how many career home runs Darren homes
gave up would you mind doing that
benefit and then we head does he does he
serve up the gopher balls Charlie yeah
he's got a real good flat for Kaymer
comes in there real nice okay pitching
to get crashes yeah now if you add any
is there any you know is there any sort
of I guess wager that you have with your
teammates because how far you're going
to last anything going on all that I we
should know about here no you know I
don't think I don't think there's a lot
of people putting their money on me you
know so I don't think anybody was
willing to throw out an odds line for
that this is every tonight so it will
just kind of have to see how it goes
okay and what about going up again were
you going up against in the in the first
round here Charlie I'll cook Bellinger
the Dodger gosh Charlie is dad's
throwing to him I mean it's such a warm
and fuzzy story you're gonna have to go
up against here yeah but you know don't
worry don't worry I'll have it I'll have
it figured out by that yeah okay well in
you and Cody Bellinger are the slightest
contestants are you aware that you're
you're just a mere to spell to 15 in
Bellinger's to 10 that's like half of an
Aaron judge I know I mean these guys
outweighs by 100 pounds it's a little
bit ridiculous now if you're 215 how
much you if you shaved your beard how
much would you way with if you shaved
your beard ah like two hundred really
like if you shaved your head and your
beard would you lay would you weigh less
than 200 pounds Charlie no no I I'm a
little beefier than that
oh gosh so how how was that yesterday
watching watching a no no potentially
get twirled in front with Kyle Freeland
yesterday I was ridiculously nervous
you're going through every possible
scenario like later in the game I feel
like what could happen and how you like
like if the ball gets in the Sun like
I'm I'm at least trying to like take it
off the chest but I get an air instead
of good to hit like it I mean it's more
nerve-wracking I felt like for me than
it was for for this the other team
trying to get the hit I guess now what
is it like in me in the dugout cause I
know you know the history of baseball is
you can't talk about it you don't you
don't even make body language about it
what was it like in a dugout as I was
kind of like business as usual nobody
talks to you know nobody talks to Kyle
you just leave him alone you don't want
to break his concentration so outside of
that there was just a normal baseball
game so then we look at the answer me
dissonant Charlie Blackmon what was the
worst small talk in the dugout and
during a potential no-hitter with your
own debates or what's going on on that
bus with your new National League
all-star teammates well we got uh-oh
we're a lot of complaining about the
travel right now
what do you mean like hey you know like
we came from the West you know a couple
hours time different so you lose a
couple hours coming East and then you
had to wake up and you know it's just
it's a lot of excuse making right pretty
good at that though real but I guess
yeah but so right now like it's
Bellinger bitching about the travel is
that what you're saying or Kershaw or
what's happening no no I think her show
through like a two-hour game yesterday
so that he could get here yeah man
that's funny yeah he did man they're
they're lights out right now the Dodgers
appear to be yeah they're hot they're
hot Charlie came all right so it's just
I talked to me about this because every
kid dreams of being an all-star you know
I mean that's that's childhood dream
stuff Charlie I mean what is this what
is this like for you being
it's honestly it's a whirlwind it's cool
and it's a lot of fun and it's a great
experience for your family but I feel
like someone's if you buzzer on the
weekend and then it's like non-stop go
go go and then just like over before you
know it and you're exhausted mm-hmm so
it's just a whirlwind experience it was
part of a Blackman policy what do you
got there ah I've got my family you know
my immediate family's here got my
girlfriend here it's just a you know a
small group but it's nice because you
know it's got so many teammates do so
yeah everybody feels comfort yeah so
what's your what's your so what is the
pre homerun Derby last couple for you
here Charlie Blackmon of the Rockies
before he participates against America's
Sweetheart um Cody Bellinger tonight in
the first round of the home run derby
and again Charlie you know good luck
absolutely destroying that feel-good
story on behalf of all American baseball
fans yeah and letters of god or son
relationships everywhere Charlie that's
no big deal so what is your what is your
pre home run derby routine are you gonna
eat something or you're gonna have
dinner what do you got Charlie what do
you got you know I'm just I'm gonna save
all my bullets not take any batting
practice before hand and just kind of
roll it out there and hope for the best
okay okay that plan I'll I can just take
it one pitch at a time so do we know how
many how many home runs is Gerren homes
given up in his career shut it out 63
home runs he's given up in his career
Kingdom hit sixty three home runs
tonight okay listen if you last the
whole Derby know know that thank you
Frank okay and so now can you do this
for me Charlie for for this for me and
for the fans of this show at one point
if you don't if you don't like one of
Darren Holmes's pitches just pull on
just when you take a pitch pull on your
beard that's a way of saying hello to me
and the entire rich eyes and show
audience and you know I'll see if I can
remember that you know promise I don't
want you to do it after a home run
because we're going to watch the ball in
flight I want to be able to see you on
camera if you just take a pitch just
think about tugging the beard just for
us all right would you mind doing that
up there
okay enjoy the enjoy the experience and
thanks for holding up that mug I saw you
took a picture of it the Rich Eisen [ __ ]
yeah it's in the mail I want to see it
on your desk like so everybody can see
well no I want you to click the mugshot
your mug that you gave me but I'm
sending you that ridiculous all water
bottle thing I didn't know that what is
that Solis notice you were holding
something we had no idea what you're
holding what is that that's coming your
way it it's one of the nicest water
bottles they have in the team store if
not the nicest one a Colorado Rockies
water bottle right and so I will be
drinking out of that ah from this from
my show desk
I'm all in Charlie you know that yeah
yeah they don't it's in roof okay good
luck tonight and tomorrow awesome thanks
thanks for it's always that's Charlie
Blackmon rocky centerfield the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience if you liked that video be sure
to download our app don't have any
memory on your phone let's start to
delete some of those slow-mo videos you
have and you know which ones I'm talking
about